hey guys it's Jan here I was super
psyched to see the first part of the
Dirt Devil season 2 trailer which gives
us a great look at the conflict between
Frank castle
aka The Punisher and Matt Murdock's
daredevil sir I wanted to break down the
trailer and explain some of the Easter
eggs and references just before I get
stuck in there will be potential
spoilers for season 2 if you want to
avoid those spoilers and get a refresh
of a season 1 check out my video 15
things you probably didn't know about
daredevil
okay this trailer is definitely all
about establishing the Punishers origin
story after a shot of castles home and
pictures of his family we get this
interesting shot of him sitting in front
of what looks like New York Central Park
Carousel with the lights clicking off
one by one this along with a creepy
sound of a child singing it's likely a
nod to how Frank Castle lost his wife
and children in the comics when they
were gunned down by mobsters in Central
Park
there's more hints that this location is
significant later in the trailer with
Punisher taking out some bad guys at the
carousel in this shot the x-ray of the
skill that Karen's handling is an Easter
Egg for the Punisher signature white
skull we see on his comic book costume
but look a bit closer at the shot from
the trailer and you'll also see Karen's
fingers run just behind a dark circle to
the left of the skull a likely reference
to the bullet wound that Frank Castle
suffered to his head during the mob
attack which killed his family also
there in the background to what looks
like case files that Karen might be
going over and there seems to be a
bloodied victim in one of the photos
with meat hanging around him which ties
in with this set photo of daredevil
standing in what looks like a
meatpacking warehouse and it's possibly
a nod to the fact that in punishes
extended world of comics video games and
movies his used equipment like meat
hooks and grinders or even meat itself
to deal with opponents for example in
the streets of Laredo comics the 1989
and 2004 Punisher movies and the 2005
Punisher video game which features a
meatpacking plant and the trailer also
alludes to the pernicious military past
in the comic books when we see some of
his weapons which is known for having
tons of in the comics and when we hear
the words about how he's taking out
gangs with military precision in the
comics Frank Castle spent time in the
Marines for years in Vietnam and also
ran black ops
missions the one batch to batch book we
see likely belonged to castles child but
given that the show's production
designer and showrunner could easily
have chosen anything to illustrate the
front cover the fact they chose burrs
feels like a nod to the time that the
Punisher used a group of polar bears in
a zoo to attack the Nutri crime family
and given castles military background
the phrase one batch to batch might be a
reference to the jessica jones character
will Simpson who is the emcee used
version of a comic book character Frank
Simpson aka nuke who underwent a super
soldier program similar to the one which
created Captain America Simpsons
medication consists of one red pill to
get him amped up two white ones to keep
him even and one blue one to bring him
down will Simpson has a military
background and the show implies what he
went through made him unstable so it'll
be interesting to see if there's any
connection in the shared universe
between him and castle the Punishers
phrase penny and dime as he goes to take
a shot could be a nod to the comic book
title ten to one from The Punisher War
Journal series and the number 10 also
seems significant given there's a number
10 card we can spot later at the scene
of a massacre or it could be a reference
to the penny and dime trick where a
penny is used to make a dime disappear
which in this case would mean that the
Punisher is making a group of bad guys
disappear while Matt's discussing his
Catholic guilt with while the lanthum we
glimpse a crucifix of what could be a
nun's habit a hint perhaps that Matt
returns to meet a nun at Saint Agnes his
orphanage we saw the orphanage which is
run by nuns briefly in a season one
flashback scene - Matt's childhood were
he met stick in the comic books we
learned that Matt's mother Maggie became
a nun called Margaret so to be
interesting to see if Matt meets her
this season by the way this is the same
orphanage that Skye from agents of
shield grew up in the DA's office gets a
mention in the trailer and seems to be
passing information on to Matt Murdock a
likely nod to the new season two
character Blake tower played by Stephen
Ryder in the comics Blake Kara's New
York's District Attorney and help stir
double cash various criminals there's
quite a bit of interaction between Matt
Murdock and Karen page in this trailer
and a hint it had likely romance between
them in the comics Karen is one of
Matt's longest-running love interest
there are also some fast cut rooftop
scenes with daredevil and the Punisher
arguing one of the shots shows daredevil
up against some bricks which is likely
the same moment from this set photo in
which the Punisher has chained up
daredevil it's an iconic moment in the
comics where daredevil finds himself in
a Sophie's Choice situation daredevil
disagrees with the Punisher taking out
criminals and believe they need to be
arrested and punished by the law
Punisher is about to kill Dino Nucci a
member of a prominent crime family and
gives daredevil gun telling him the only
way to stop him shooting Nucci is to
kill the Punisher himself in either case
daredevil has to murder someone himself
or let someone be murdered it's a really
great scene and later in the comics the
Punisher sets daredevil free after
knocking him out which is likely why we
see him later in the trailer using a
chain to fight in a couple of shots the
finishers line - daredevil that you're
one bad day away from being me goes back
to the dirt devil comics and also
reminded me of the Joker's one bad day
line in the Batman comic The Killing
Joke we also get a look at two different
daredevil masks in the trailer here we
see the same red mask he had at the end
of season 1 and later he's wearing a
black mask the black mask is damaged in
this shot but it matches the black mask
and one of the official set photos and
to cap off the awesome trailer we get an
introduction to Elodie Young's Elektra
who we see already knows that there was
a reference to her and see someone when
foggy asked Mass about the Greek girl he
dated in college and matt said it didn't
work out between them in the comics
Electra is the daughter of a Greek
ambassador is trained in martial arts
and has had an on-off relationship with
Matt Murdock I'll have more discussion
of Elektra in my video about Potts who
of the trailer but it's worth pointing
out now that we didn't actually get to
see Wilson Fisk return yes in this
trailer I'm hopeful he will be in season
two as he highs Elektra as a bodyguard
in the comics to protect himself against
the Punisher so what other Easter eggs
did you spot in the trailer and what do
you think about Jon Bernthal as The
Punisher let me know in the comments
below
next week I'll have another breakdown an
easter egg review of the part 2 trailer
so do make sure you subscribe to get
that and in the meantime why not take a
look at some of my other videos
including 15 cool behind-the-scenes
facts about the
of daredevil Jessica Jones season one
Easter eggs and Deadpool Easter eggs
thanks for watching
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers